What's up, gamers?
A lot of SCP fans have played the free survival
horror game "SCP - Containment Breach."
The game's story places the player in the
shoes of a D-Class at one of the Foundation's
containment sites, as they try their best
to survive a massive, catastrophic containment
breach.
Many players, including some of our viewers,
feel as if the simulated experience has given
them the tools they would need to survive
a real-life containment breach.
But can playing a video game really be sufficient
training for encountering some of the deadliest
SCPs in containment and escaping with your
life?
In order to answer this question, we're going
to speculate based on one of the game's most
prolific players: famous YouTuber and gamer
Markiplier.
If playing this game counts as training, then
Markiplier has enough hours logged to be a
bona fide expert in facing off against the
many dangerous anomalies at the SCP Foundation.
So kick back, crack open some G Fuel, and
let's see if Markiplier lives to game another
day.
To set the scene, let's all imagine that somehow,
through a hiccup in time and space or by some
sort of wish on a cursed monkey's paw, Markiplier
found himself inside of an SCP Foundation
containment site.
That would be bad enough, but the blaring
alarms and sounds of chaos signal that he
arrived at the worst possible time: during
a containment breach.
The security systems are down, the cells are
open, and danger lurks around every corner.
Armed with nothing but his wits and winning
personality, the only thing he can do is try
to navigate the facility as carefully as possible,
remember everything he's learned from his
time streaming the video game version of this
place, and hope he can escape with his life.
Let's start with one we know he'd be well-equipped
to face: SCP-173.
The neck-snapping sculpture is the main antagonist
of "SCP Containment Breach," so Markiplier
would be familiar with the necessary precautions
to avoid winding up as its next victim.
If he happened to walk into a room and spot
the figure, frozen in his gaze, he would know
to keep his eyes on the sculpture no matter
what, and slowly back out of the room without
blinking.
Plus, with all of the time he spends looking
at screens, he's definitely used to keeping
his eyes on one thing for a long period of
time!
Congratulations, Mark!
You survived that one.
He's managed to get away from SCP-173 with
his neck still intact, hooray!
But as he sneaks through the hall, trying
not to draw any unwanted attention, a french-accented
voice breaks the silence behind him.
"Good evening, my fine fellow!
Are you feeling quite well?"
There, behind him, is the SCP-049, the Plague
Doctor, in all of his beak-masked, black-robed
glory.
"You look feverish.
Please, allow me to administer some simple
tests..."
In this scenario, Mark would have to think
fast and use some of that patented Markiplier
charm to get himself out of a potentially
sticky situation before one of those gloved
hands can touch him.
He would need to politely excuse himself,
insist that he just saw his doctor earlier
that day, and then, before the Plague Doctor
can take another step closer, run as fast
as he possibly could in the opposite direction.
As Markiplier stops to catch his breath, having
thrown the Plague Doctor off of his trail,
the sound of sobbing in the corner signals
that he might have just escaped the proverbial
frying pan only to wind up in the fire.
A quick cursory glance up, and the sight of
a long-limbed, pale humanoid form, would confirm
his suspicions: yes, indeed, he's found himself
alone with SCP-096, the Shy Guy.
Remembering the details of this particular
anomaly from the game, he would look back
down at the ground immediately, making sure
not to glimpse the creature's face.
As long as he avoided looking at its face,
it would stay in the corner of the room, scarcely
even acknowledging him.
Then, he would be free to make a mad dash
for the exit.
All the while, SCP-096 would stay hunched
over, crying, and completely unaware it was
briefly in the presence of a beloved YouTube
personality.
Things might be going pretty well for Markiplier
so far, but uh oh!
What's that sound?
The slither of tentacles on tile, the thumping
of a large heart, and the murmuring voice
of...an elderly Englishman?
Poor Markiplier, video games definitely wouldn't
have prepared him for the arrival of SCP-058,
the Heart of Darkness.
It's come out of its cage, and it's doing
just fine, but the same can't be said for
any living thing that this creepy animate,
and highly hostile, creature encounters.
"Endless suffering is the woe of ignorant
men who never lack to seek the depth of their
own hearts and only see the wealth of a poor
world suffering of silver and brutal gladness,"
the heart whispers, as it scuttles toward
the hapless YouTuber.
Without much prior knowledge of the anomaly,
Mark would be thoroughly unprepared for an
encounter with it.
He would likely fall victim to its spiked
tentacles or the sharp stinger, and any attempt
to physically fight it off would be ineffective,
due to the anomaly's resilience to physical
attacks.
We don't need to get into the details of how
that specifically might end.
It would be a bit tasteless.
But there are friendly anomalies that Markiplier
might stumble upon too!
Suppose, instead of suffering an untimely
end at the tentacles of a heart monster that
speaks in creepy atmospheric gibberish, he
found himself face to face with SCP-073, Cain?
It would be a nice reprieve, to be sure, as
Cain is generally pleasant and congenial to
any humans he meets.
You never know, he might even be a fan of
Mark's work.
The same can't be said for Cain's counterpart,
SCP-076, however.
It's nothing personal, Able feels murderous
rage toward any and all human beings.
But it's hard not to take it personally when
you see Able running at you at full speed,
brandishing a massive sword that's poised
to take your head off with one swing.
If Markiplier faced Able on his own, he would
unfortunately not stand much of a chance.
Again, it's nothing personal, he's a super
powerful ancient warrior with a taste for
bloodshed.
If Cain was in the vicinity, however, then
he might just escape unscathed.
Cain is one of the few anomalies that can
easily oppose Able, as any damage Able manages
to do to him will only affect Able.
So, the best case scenario for Mark would
be to let the two immortals go at it, while
he sneaks away quietly.
After all the stress of navigating the containment
site, Markiplier would probably really need
some cheering up.
After all, his entire sense of reality is
crumbling around him at a rapid pace.
Good news, because SCP-999 can always sense
when someone nearby needs that frown turned
upside down.
The Tickle Monster doesn't appear in the Containment
Breach game, so Mark might not know what to
expect when he sees a large mass of bright
orange slime oozing toward him at a rapid
pace.
But once SCP-999 wrapped him in a big hug,
and its natural mood-boosting properties kicked
in, he would know that this particular creature
is friend, not foe.
He would give the slimy visitor some affectionate
pats, and the Tickle Monster would coo happily
in return.
SCP-999 might try to follow Markiplier down
the hall, but he would insist it stay where
it is needed, helping the various humans and
anomalies of the Foundation when they need
a little bit of sweetness and light in their
lives.
Then, the two would part ways, each with their
spirits lifted, and with fond memories of
their new friend that would last a lifetime.
But you can never let your guard down at the
SCP Foundation, not for even a second as you're
enjoying a hug from everyone's favorite happy
slime creature.
If you relax and forget to keep your wits
about you, you might not notice the wall behind
you starting to warp and melt as something
horrible reaches through it, from a dark place
outside of space and time.
If Markiplier turned around to find himself
face to face with the cold, dead eyes of SCP-106,
The Old Man, what would happen next?
The rotten Old Man appears in Containment
Breach, so Mark would know exactly how bad
things can get if this ominous octogenarian
gets his decaying hands on him.
He would also know that doors, walls, and
other solid objects are not enough to deter
this entity once he sets his sights on taking
you.
It's possible that Mark could run, could stay
out of the Old Man's sight until the creature
gets bored or finds some other, more convenient
prey to snatch up.
But it's more likely that SCP-106 would be
excited by the chase, and would delight in
the fear and pain that he is causing.
Unlike in Containment Breach, where SCP-106's
movements can be predicted, the real thing
is far more crafty and malicious.
And there's no starting over if the Old Man
catches up to you in the real world.
Unfortunately, Markiplier would likely find
himself pulled through the wall and into the
entity's lair, where only doom would be waiting.
How might Markiplier fare against another
prominent character in Containment Breach,
though?
Say...one very tricky Possessive Mask?
Thankfully, his experience with the game would
have taught Mark in advance that SCP-035 cannot
be trusted under any circumstances.
However, the mask in the game is at least
a little bit helpful, offering valuable information
about navigating the Containment Site, and
even providing insight into other threats
to the player's safety.
The real thing is nowhere near as generous.
It has no desire to help humans, or anyone
but itself, really.
If it wound up in the same room as Markiplier,
it would have one goal and one goal only:
Get him to take it out of its case, and put
it over his face.
Hopefully, Markiplier would know better than
to wear the wicked porcelain mask, but its
psychic influence is strong.
We couldn't blame him if he wound up succumbing
to it, putting it on and becoming the Mask's
newest human host.
It would be thrilled to have found such a
famous body to take over, too.
It would pilot Markiplier out of the containment
site, take him back home, and become the first
SCP with over one million YouTube subscribers
- aside from this channel, of course.
I shudder to think what SCP-035 would do with
such a massive platform.
It definitely wouldn't be anything good.
Now, there aren't just anomalies at the Foundation.
There are lots of staff members, working to
keep the well-oiled machine running smoothly.
Of course, some are better at this than others,
and some staff are just agents of chaos all
on their own.
But that makes life more fun!
Imagine a team-up between the most fun-loving,
memeable researcher at the SCP Foundation
and Markiplier.
That's right, Dr. Jack Bright himself.
Now, many people don't know this, but Dr.
Bright is a big fan of gaming YouTubers, and
has wanted to start a channel of his own for
quite some time.
The Foundation won't allow him to run any
of his own social media, concerned about the
potential for secure information leaking to
the public.
But a chance encounter with one of his favorite
YouTuber creators would be just the kind of
opportunity Dr. Bright has been waiting for!
Sure, Markiplier might be a bit caught off
guard by a strange man in an amulet asking
him to collab, but Dr. Bright's big personality,
sense of humor, and high energy would make
him a great guest to have on the channel.
At least until he finds something else to
distract him from his own existential dread,
and abandons his streaming dreams for that.
He'd definitely get Markiplier to autograph
the amulet first, though.
That's for sure.
Lots of people love Markiplier, he's a congenial
guy with a passion for making enjoyable content!
But there's one anomaly at the Foundation
that wouldn't like him at all.
In fact, it would find him, frankly, disgusssssting.
But that's not his fault, SCP-682 hates all
living things.
That's kind of its whole deal.
Well, that, and being impossible to kill.
The massive, rage-filled reptile is incredibly
dangerous to anything and anyone it encounters,
and, sadly, Markiplier would be no exception.
This creature doesn't care about likability,
or how much a person has contributed to contemporary
internet culture.
It only cares about destruction, about snapping
the poor YouTuber up in its jaws or knocking
him into the wall with one swish of its enormous
tail.
Unless Markiplier happened to have a spare
nuclear warhead on him, it's not likely that
he would make it out of a meeting with SCP-682
in one piece.
Oh, no, not his head- WAIT, is that the bite
of 87?!
Speaking of 87, how would Markiplier fare
if he stumbled upon SCP-087, The Stairwell?
It's not the likeliest of events, seeing as
the doorway leading to it is constructed of
reinforced steel with an electro-release lock,
and disguised as the entrance to a janitor's
closet in an undisclosed building, but in
this world, stranger things have happened.
Markiplier has played more than enough horror
games to know that finding yourself in a dark
staircase that seems to go on forever, where
you can hear the distant cries of a distressed
child, isn't something anyone would ever want.
He could try and descend the staircase, looking
for a way out, but if he did, all that would
await him is creeping dread and paranoia,
and an encounter with the frightening face
of SCP-087-1.
His best hope in this scenario would be to
take a seat at the top of the stairs, and
wait for his loyal fan base to notice he hasn't
been online for a while.
The internet is a powerful thing, and it's
possible they could track him down and rescue
him before things got too dire.
Otherwise...well, best not to think about
that.
Over the span of their careers, many online
personalities and digital content creators
have found themselves in need of a rebrand.
Maybe they decide to make a new type of creative
work, maybe they wind up at the center of
a scandal, or maybe they just get bored of
doing the same thing over and over again.
If Markiplier ever decided to change things
up, there are dozens of ways he could go about
it.
But there's one that he would need to visit
the SCP Foundation for.
It wouldn't be necessarily advisable, but
what if Markiplier decided to engage in some
anomalous self-improvement using SCP-914,
the Clockworks?
Using live test subjects with this machine
is always a bit dicey, and he would need to
be extremely careful about what setting he
used.
The Very Fine setting could produce some really
exciting results.
Maybe it would improve his eyesight, or give
him the ability to work long hours without
experiencing creator burnout.
Maybe it would give him the ability to fly,
or to spontaneously generate a WiFi hotspot
no matter where he was, or how little phone
signal he had.
Maybe it would make him the greatest gamer
in the world.
There's really only one reason to find out...
Just make sure to hit the right button or
several million people would be very very
sad.
Speaking of self-improvement, what would happen
if Markiplier got his hands on an anomalous
computer program?
Not one of the dangerous ones, but an educational
one intended to help children learn new skills.
SCP-5094, Miss J's Whiz Kid Schoolhouse, would
be a perfect fit.
He'd have to find a way to play it on his
computer, but once he did, Markiplier could
livestream his experience with the software.
It's uncertain how the anomalous effect of
SCP-5094 would translate to a massive audience,
but it would be amazing to see if thousands
of people could learn a new skill at once.
It wouldn't just be entertaining, it would
be potentially life-changing for everyone
involved.
Speaking of helpful anomalies, Markiplier
would greatly benefit from an introduction
to SCP-662, the Butler's Hand Bell.
Running a YouTube channel takes a ton of work,
and having an eager, supernatural assistant
on call 24 hours a day would probably really
improve the quality of life for everyone involved.
Mr. Deeds would be happy to assist with whatever
day-to-day tasks might come up, and could
even become a beloved background character
on the channel.
Whether it's bringing Mark a bag of Taki's
or helping edit video footage, there's very
little this helpful British Butler can't do!
When you get famous and successful, and when
you become a public figure online it seems
like everyone out there wants a piece of you.
People want money, attention, to ride someone's
coattails to fame.
But what about an anomaly that quite literally
wants a piece of Markiplier?
Or any person, really?
SCP-082, Fernand the Cannibal, would love
to meet Markiplier, and would love to make
Markiplier his meat.
He would probably use his habit for lying
and spinning elaborate stories, to attempt
to entice Mark into a dangerous situation.
"Hello Markiplier, it's me, your friend Jacksepticeye!"
he would say, while very visibly not being
who he claims to be.
"It's time to film a new video challenge,
see how long you can stay in the soup pot!
Just hop in this pot of boiling water, don't
mind me cutting up carrots and onions into
it..."
As long as Mark keeps his wits about him and
doesn't fall for the extremely obvious lies,
he would likely escape this confrontation
without ending up in a YouTuber Stew.
Markiplier is somewhat familiar with the layout
of the SCP Foundation containment site, thanks
to the gameplay of "Containment Breach."
But what if, after freeing himself from one
anomalous nightmare, he stumbled into another
one altogether?
What if, months after his inexplicable teleportation
into the containment site, after life was
starting to get back to normal, he was in
the market for a brand new gaming chair?
And what if he decided to prioritize convenience
and Scandinavian furniture engineering in
his selection process?
And what if, on top of all that, he had a
craving for some Swedish meatballs consumed
in a public food court?
Why, all of those factors might just lead
him to Ikea.
And while there are hundreds of Ikeas around
the country, it's not impossible that he might
just pick the wrong one, and find himself
lost inside of SCP-3008.
Markiplier is a fairly observant guy, so it
likely wouldn't take him too long to notice
that something is a bit off inside of this
particular retail store.
There wouldn't be any other shoppers around
him, the aisles would go on forever, and the
employees inside wouldn't have faces.
That last one would probably be the biggest
giveaway.
Unfortunately, once someone is inside the
Infinite Ikea, it's pretty unlikely that they
will ever leave.
He would give it a noble effort, to be sure,
exploring his surroundings and finding the
best places to hide from the Ikea Staff when
the lights go out.
If his phone is fully charged, he might even
be the first person to livestream from the
depths of this anomalous furniture outlet,
and spread the word to his fans about the
existence of SCP-3008.
But sadly, that stream would probably wind
up being his last, unless he somehow figured
out a way to recreate his YouTube setup inside
of his strange new home.
If he did, though, that would be pretty cool!
Almost cool enough to make up for the fact
that he would never see any of his friends
or family ever again.
Fortunately for everyone involved, it's highly
unlikely that Markiplier will end up interacting
with any SCP anomalies without the safe barrier
of a computer monitor in between them.
But just in case reality ever bends in on
itself and worlds begin to collide, hopefully
Mark will remember everything he's learned.
And, to anyone who's ever told you otherwise:
see?
Playing video games can help you in the real
world!
It might even save your life.
Now go check out “SCP-963 What Would You
Do If You Were Immortal Like Dr. Jack Bright?”
and “The Whole Story!
- What if SCP-096 Wore SCP-035?”
for more utterly bizarre What Ifs!